hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time for our monthly meetup to look
through the PS Plus offerings this time
for March 2018 every single one of these
games will be available from Tuesday the
6th of March and 5 out of the 6 games
will be available on your ps4 so if you
are ready let's start off with the
flagship offerings on the PlayStation 4
first up is the action role-playing game
which will engulf your life blood-borne
released three years ago blood bomb took
RPGs up to a new level of difficulty and
brutality so prepare to die so many
times you will cry blood-borne tells the
story of a hunter in a town filled with
an abnormal blood-borne disease cursing
the inhabitants your final goal is to
rid this place of that plague but on the
way you'll face countless enemies and
multiple boss battles which may cause
you to smash your controllers at pieces
the difficulty curve is quite high but
always fair learn from your mistakes and
beat the damn game
if you dare the combat is fast paced
with an impressive risk reward mechanic
based around perfect timing to dodge or
counter edge magazine gave this one the
perfect 10 out of 10 and I couldn't find
a review scarf below 9 out of 10 blood
font is brutal but brilliant are you
going to try it please let me know your
thoughts in the comments and if you're a
blood-borne vet give us some advice I
guarantee we will need it back on the
ps2 the brilliance of ratchet & clank
was released on to the world and then
last year the original game received a
reimagining on the ps4 this means if
you've played the original you'll have
an overwhelming sense of nostalgia but
you won't know all the story beats and
if you're new to the series what's a
great place to start as ratchets a young
LOM Brax mechanic who dreams of joining
the galactic rangers his partner in
crime is Clank who's also playable
numerous times during the course of the
game the story feels a great deal like
the original Star Wars saga but in the
quirky platforming style the weapons and
gadgets used are varied and plentiful
and there's even a movie which sits
alongside if you become more invested
than you first thought oh the developer
behind this one insomnia
are currently making the ps4 version of
spider-man so now is a good time to
sample their work on the ps3 is mighty
number 9 which is also a cross by title
so play it on your ps4 if you like
mighty number 9 is the successor to
Megaman in every single way except
officially created by Megaman supremo
Keiji Inafune a this game is a 2.5 D
action platformer with a focus on speedy
combat the lead character is called beck
running through nine stages which can be
selected in any order the player desires
the story isn't plentiful but as a
starting point a computer virus has
caused Beck's
robot friends to go rogue and Megaman is
here to put things right
did I say Megaman I mean back of course
are you gonna try it out of interest
will you play it on ps4 or ps3 the
second title on ps3 is a game which came
out on the ps2 and was re-released with
improved graphics
The Legend of K anniversary edition it's
another action-adventure title with lots
of platforming elements thrown in for
good measure the story focuses around K
a bit of a hothead martial arts student
think of it like an angsty teenage
version of Kung Fu Panda and you're
pretty much on point
back in 2010 The Legend of K received
favorable reviews but eight years on it
kind of feels a little dated let me know
your thoughts if you download this one
on the Vita this month are two games
which can be played on your ps4 first up
is Claire extended Curt which is our
horror title for the month it's
essentially a 2d side-scroller with very
mixed reviews you fill the shoes of
Claire who makes a typical horror film
error and takes a wrong turn down a dark
passage leading to echoey corridors and
abandoned rooms the panic Claire feels
impacts the game and in nightmare mode
she can even die from fear itself the
decisions you make on the way to the
ending impact that ending so expect to
play multiple times to see all the
possible ending cinematics and finally
on Vita and ps4 is bomb Busters I'm
super excited by this one as it's
essentially super Bomberman from the
Super Nintendo days this is so
old-school and is
your time especially in a party scenario
as you attempt to blow up your friends
from the safety of your own couch as
long as the host is playing on ps4 and
both Vita and ps4 users can match up and
fight it's usually a case of
what-you-see-is-what-you-get
but believe me it's far more appealing
once your competitive edge kicks in I
could only find a couple of reviews for
this one and one was from our friends
over at push square who awarded it 60
out of 100 so there we have it six games
on offer during March with 5
downloadable TRPs for I could get used
to this for me I need to play bomb
Busters and I promised myself I'll
finally finish blood-borne but what
about you what floats your boat I'd love
to know what you think I imagine from
PlayStation grenade it's been a pleasure
as always
I'll see you next time